hey everyone I'm Cody and welcome to a
video where I'm going to show you how to
build a Jas a JavaScript connect for
game using jQuery JavaScript html5 CSS
whatnot and let's go ahead and get
started right so obviously you know what
connect four is or you should so if you
don't all go to Connect four
images
tech forces game where you have this
grid and each player can alternate
taking terms placing their color circle
so we're gonna try to build that which
basically whenever you get four in a row
you win the game so that's kind of a
reference that we can go off of
let's go ahead and get started so on the
Left I have an empty project over here
which has absolutely no files in it it's
just a blank git repo and on the right I
have that project hosted using HTTP -
server which is a node module you can
use if you want to host them like HTML
files or whatnot that's kind of my set
up
start off how would you build a website
or a web page which displays a grid that
has this type of structure in it like
here is a good example I guess we can go
off of
so to start off we need to first build
up a blank HTML file if I go over here
and just say new file index.html so here
we can actually write our HTML file if
we want to and say build an HTML we need
a head
and we need a body
inside the head let's go we can get a
title and call it connect or and also
inside here we can start including some
things the first thing want to do is
include a Al sheet
I'm gonna say there's a local stylesheet
hosted in this folder which we can add
in one second now call it style dot CSS
I'd make this font a little bit smaller
so we can see it
so this page is going to load in style
about CSS which we haven't created yet
so I'll go ahead and just create a dial
not CSS and I'm also going to create a
main J's file
we can just go ahead and import that as
well up here I'm going to go to add a
new element called script I'm going to
first include main J s
I can just do something simpler like a
little world just to make sure this is
working and if I were to refresh the
page we have hello world printing out
and inside the console dev tools if I
were to go to the console over here
I want to make sure that this may not
jeaious thing is loading and running
correctly I can go over to my main J's
file and say console dot log here save
that file and refresh this page and we
get here int it out
all right so we have our basic setup
going and again we can just test to make
sure that the body is working so I can
say background color is orange save that
and it is refreshing the screen using
live with the reload on the background
so if you remember I did mention that
we're going to be using jQuery and I'm
mainly using jQuery because it has a lot
of helper functions which allow us to do
our job much more efficiently than using
vanilla JavaScript
might be kind of overkill but I like to
use it just because it's really easy to
select stuff and change data on stuff
and whatnot so I'm going to go ahead and
go to CD nsj and search for jQuery and
I'll go ahead and grab the jQuery Minjae
s copy this and then over here I can
just
first of all close my editor
you can load that script in here
that it is working I can say
document.ready
gonna go ahead and print out working if
that is in day if that is indeed working
I saw his money sign is not defined
that's because I loaded it jQuery after
main so of course you need to load it
before you run your script and now we
get to working printed out to the
console so now we have jQuery working we
have our style sheets hooked up and we
have our main J's file running as
expected
so to start off what we want to do is we
want but over to that body background
color is we want to first figure out a
way to dynamically build up a grid
so inside our body if we were to just go
ahead and make a div and call it Connect
four or something
that connect for div with some rows and
columns that kind of show a grid that
looks like this if you notice you have
one two three four five six seven
columns and six rows
so what we can do in our main.js file
is I'm going to go ahead and just clear
at those console logs
and just do a little to do here so he
said to draw a grid
and they kind of help abstract this into
different modules what I'm going to do
first of all is make a connect or file
and also include that right above main
and what we're going to do inside
Connect four
I include Connect four as a script
I have Connect four over here basically
what Connect four is going to do is
declare a class called Connect four
which we can use in our main file so I'm
going to go ahead and just type this out
I'll make a class called Connect four
I'll give it a constructor
Rose is equal to six and this dot alms
is equal to seven
you
over here I mean I could just say make
us a new grid
new Kinect for object so up here I can
say a Const
next four is equal to new Connect four
and I'm going to go ahead and pass it
some type of selector so I'm just going
to a string and you know this is up to
us this is we can customize it however
you want to but our constructor is going
to take a selector so over here I pass
in selector
it knows where to render the grid if you
remember on our HTML file we have an ID
called connect for so what we want to do
is inside main je s we're going to pass
that elements or that ID of Connect four
into this new connect four object and
what we want our connect four class to
do is just go ahead and build up a grid
so they kind of just show you what
exactly is going on and kind of jumping
around first thing I'm going to do is
just to demonstrate I can say grid is
equal to use jQuery and grab that
selector and then I can say grid die
hTML is equal to
hello
so now when I say this notice that what
it's doing is main is running it's
creating this connect for object asking
the selector and then the connect for
class is grabbing the selector grabbing
the div and then adding it HTML to the
inside of that div alright so that's
pretty awesome so what we want to do at
this point again is we're trying to
build that 6 by 7 grid so I'm going to
go ahead and create a method on this
connector for class called create and
grid and the purpose of this function is
to basically build up a bunch of divs
like you know six different rows inside
each row we have seven different columns
and we're gonna go ahead and call this
top create grid here so whenever this
connect for object initializes we're
going to go ahead and create the HTML
for the grid and I'm going to go ahead
and just get rid of these things and
keep track of that selector that was
passed in
so to start off how would we create a
grid the first thing I want to do is I
want to grab that Dom element so I guess
a constant board is equal to a query of
this not selector and that should give
us if I were to print this out
should give us the div of Connect four
and inside of this Connect four div we
want to go ahead and just loop over and
create six rows but one way you could do
that is obviously use a for loop so set
let Rho is equal to zero and say Rho is
less than this tile rows and robust plus
now do the same thing with the columns
here
instead of let roll say let column
I'll take a step back so I don't confuse
you all yet so let's just serve the row
so for each row what we're going to do
is create a new div so I'll say constant
row and the way I kind of use this money
sign in front of variable names it's
just so I know that it's a jQuery object
this is just my convention you don't
have to follow this but just easily lets
me know that hey this is a jQuery object
that we're messing with but we're saying
constant money sign a row is equal to
and I'm going to create a new of using
jQuery and to do that you just do money
sign and pass it the name of the Dom
element you want to create in this case
is div and I'm just going to go ahead
and add a class to it called row
and then of course I can say board and
dog to the pinned bro
and now if I were to print out the board
after here
we see that the board has actually might
print out the HTML of the board
the board now has a bunch of rows nested
inside of it and in course I can go here
just kind of demonstrate that we have a
div called ID Connect four and inside
that we're creating six rows those six
divs with the class row inside here so
that's step one right we need to create
six rows and the second step is we need
to create seven columns inside of each
of those rows so instead I can add
another for loop here
and again the one I put out a second ago
I'm just going to loop over the columns
down
and for every iteration of this for loop
I'm gonna stay constant call is equal to
and then let's go ahead and create
another div
a class of call and empty so you can
kind of style it and you know give it a
style of when it is empty versus when it
has a red or a black token inside of it
and I think that should be good for
there and I need to append that column
if I say I'm gonna sign road pinned and
then up in the column unto the row
and then for Ichiro we append into the
board order to save this now
going to the body we have a div called
Connect four it has six rows and in each
side each row it has seven columns so
the Dom element structure is there ready
to go but we still don't really
visualize it so what we can do at this
point is if we can dive into the style
at CSS and the first thing I want to do
is just add a couple of attributes ooh
first of all it connects for object
which is our grid and we want to set the
background color to yellow
and we want to make it
display:inline-block
the body I'm just going to go
text-align:center so that the grid is
centered
so again this made everything centered
and this made the rhythmic with the
background color of yellow which we
can't see right now because it has no
height but we will visualize that in one
second
so for every column that we have on the
page we want to give it a particular
width in height I'll say width is equal
to 70 pixels
I do height is equal to 70 pixels save
that and then so you saw here it kind of
created all those but they're all on one
like column which is not what we want so
we can just go ahead and do a
display:inline-block on the columns and
that makes them all appear on the same
row or were to hover over them you see
that we have these columns side by side
and that's because we added
display:inline-block on line 13
almost done with this first I'll set the
background color to white and I'm going
to add a border a radius of 50% to make
it round
and finally who you probably add some
margin over all the slots just so it
looks more like a grid
that wasn't too difficult let me just do
a really quick recap so we're not really
confused as to what just happened
so inside this connect for class we all
create grid when the constructor is
called and inside this constructor we
basically loop over every row and create
a div called row which you can see here
and then inside of every row we disap in
seven different columns and then we went
ahead and just add a bunch of different
styles so it makes it look more like a
next for grid so not not too difficult
right and jQuery allows us to do this
type of logic much more simple than just
using vanilla j/s where you have to do
like about query selector and if you
want to add a class or remove a class
you'd have to do a bunch of other in my
opinion just a khaki ways to do it
versus jQuery just gives you really
useful utility functions to do with the
same thing
go ahead and minimize this a little bit
so we have a grid again and what we can
do at this point the next thing we're
trying to achieve
in fact before I go too much further let
me just go ahead and commit what I have
so I'll say a grid or initial setup of
grid
and that
Oh hit it
that I mean
and again as we work through this
project I'm going to be committing and
pushing stuff to our repo if you were to
go here and you wanted to actually kind
of walk through how we did this stuff
you could just look through all the
different commits here and then first
one I did an initial setup of a grid
which has all of these different changes
and of course I'll add a read mean a
little bit so you can actually run this
is to read me MD really quick
and we'll come back to that at the very
animal I'll explain how you can run this
easily on your computer
all righty so now for the next step what
we want to do is as you hover over the
cells in this grid we want to go ahead
and just drop different colors so the
easiest way to do that or at least the
way I'm going to do it in this tutorial
is I'm going to create another function
inside this class which is going to set
up event listeners
and again there's more than one way to
put this up so if you find a better way
to do this or you think of a more
elegant solution feel free to do it and
give me a feedback but this is just the
way that I feel is a decent solution for
this project so the first thing we want
to do is call a setup event listeners
here
so basically when we create the grid
we're going to create a bunch of int
listeners but you're going to listen to
different things such as hover events
click events or whatnot
so the first thing I think would be
useful is we want to kind of when we
enter one of these columns or cells we
want to place a indicator as to where
the piece is going to drop this again if
you have like three pieces here already
and you're hovering over this column it
should drop it at this location
the first thing let's just go ahead and
do constant board is equal to this
selector
again I'm just grabbing that Dom element
I'll connect for our ID of Connect four
and we're gonna do a different listeners
on that so I can say the first one is
board dot on Mouse enter and then this
is a jQuery method where you pass it the
events you want to listen to the second
argument is going to be the selector
you're going to listen to as well so I'm
say whenever we click on or hover over
sorry an empty column let's invoke a
function
make this font a little bit smaller so
we can see everything on one page back
to probably
this a little bit because we're going to
be using more than that grid
okay so basically when we enter one of
these cells so I'll say ear and out cell
that we've entered
to the console now as we hover over
these cells notice that it's printing
out the different cells that we've over
add event listeners using jQuery on
different Dom elements
these are set up when the constructor is
ran for Connect four so basically the
moment we call new Connect four and
passes a selector it's going to set up
those event listeners
okay so again what we're trying to do is
when you hover over or one of these
pieces it's going to put an indicator at
the bottom so how do we do that
the first thing I think you need to know
is how do we know which column or row
that we've hovered over in this case we
just need to know the column ID right so
we can't really you know duel there's
not really good way to do that I guess
so what we can do is go back to when
we're creating the grid and we can add
different attributes to the column so
here I could say add attribute
it's just attr instead of at its attr
and i can pass the attribute i want to
add so I could say data call and then of
course we want to give it the attribute
of column index and then here for row
which we'll use later on we're going to
go ahead and give it D the row index
here so here you have the row index
which will be 0 through 5 and then here
would be the column index was just 0
through 6
now at this point if I save this and we
were to hover over we see that now every
time we hover over a different column we
have a easy way to grab you know which
index like zero zero being the top left
as we go down we get the zero five and
as we go to the far bottom-right corner
we get two six five
again we use these to attribute methods
and jQuery to just go ahead and add an
attribute to the cell and then over here
what we could easily do is just write
those out
so if I were to say onca column is equal
to money sign this dot ADA of column
then print out what column is equal to
and go ahead and save that notice that
it's going to print out 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 as
I hover over things
in my ass okay so what was the purpose
of that why do we why do we need to get
the column index so again we need to
kind of when we hover over column let's
say one we need to grab all of the cells
in that column and loop it backwards
over them until we find an empty one and
once we do find an empty one we can just
go ahead and change the look of that two
column
but might not make too much sense let me
just go ahead and start working on
coding it up and we will see what I mean
so what we want to do again is as we
hover over one of these cells we're
going to get the last empty cell that's
in that column so let's just first
assume that we have a method that we can
do that so we get a console ass empty
cell is equal to fine last empty cell
and then pass at the column index
so up here inside setup event listeners
we can just go ahead and declare that
function
in assuming that it does return
something that we can use we could just
go ahead and add a class to it so last
empty cell dot add class
is equal to I'm just going to do
something called next I'll say red
probably change the name of this later
in a second but of course if we had a
style called next read we could just
change the background color
ooh
[Music]
red value with some opacity
really really really faint red if we
hover over one of the columns
arrange this
okay so now we want to implement that
fine last empty cell method to define up
here on line 29 so to do that remember
what were we trying to do is we need to
grab all of these cells in that column
that we selected so the way to do that
using jQuery is we could say Const cells
equal to and then using jQuery they grab
me all the columns that have the same
attribute data - column if you remember
we added that earlier on equal to the
column index that we passed in
I would print outlets elza's at this
point we should get an array of a lot of
different elements as we hover over
stuff
i'ma see AG class of all right now comp
that out because it's not going to work
as intended
now I hovered over something and I go
here and we have a
harpus ensure that this is working yet
because I forgot to put a colon there or
a comma there
okay there
so I added this single quote here and
that fixed the bug and basically now
when we hover over one of these columns
is going to show us all of the cells
that are in that column and so kind of
visualizing here what we need to do
programmatically is we just need to
start at the very end and just keep
looping backwards until we find an empty
one and it turns out in all these cases
these are all empty so we can just grab
the last one if it's empty we just add a
class or remove a class empty from it
and we could just add something else to
it
so in this one I'll say loop over all of
these things backwards
and then grab the cell that we're
currently at I'll say cells of I
basically again we loop over backwards
we get the jQuery representation of the
cell that we're at and we say if the
cell has a class of empty
we want to just go ahead and return that
cell and otherwise if we just returned
all
but now this method will just return is
the last jQuery instance that has an
empty class attached to it if I already
go down here and then of course add that
new class
notice that as we hover it's going to
add up a place alert at the bottom and
of course we need to add 8 if a mouse
leave event that kind of remove that
class so let's go ahead and just work on
fixing that bug and it shouldn't be too
difficult
basically inside the set of event
listeners what we can do is add another
on all back function so I'll say on
Mouse leave and if this is invoked on
any column we could just say all a
function and then of course we can say
remove all of the classes that have next
read match them
now as we hover over
is going to remove the last one that it
added and of course there's probably
other ways to do this but um this is a
decent way that comes to mind just from
coding so let's go ahead and commit this
to the repo this is a good
good functionality we added so I'm going
to go ahead and say added functionality
for hovering over columns go ahead and
add that
push that
and just make sure that it's here now
and we have
just now we updated some stuff
so now if you want to see the
functionality changes from setting up
the initial grid to seeing these event
listeners you can do so by just simply
clicking commits here
and then viewing the commits
sorry so right now at this point what we
can do is if we were to click on one of
these columns we want to go ahead and
just place a piece in the bottom row or
wherever the next quote-unquote slot
should be
again we could just add another listener
she's going to be a signboard on click
and then if we click on an empty
sell or empty Dom element that has the
class empty
what we can do is again we know what we
clicked on so we can get the column and
the row so I'll say cons to call is
equal to this data all
and then same thing with RO so we know
which column in RO was clicked
I'm not sure if we even need this at
this point but it would be good to know
I'm so remember yeah if we were to the
saying an example if we were hovering
over this one here and we click it we
want to place the players token or the
circle at the very last one so we can
call that same method called fine last
empty cell
and pass it the column index which will
give us that last empty cell
and then what we can do is just simply
remove the empty from it so I can say
last empty cell remove class of empty
boo class empty and then last empty cell
could add a class of red
in fact I'll get rid of real for now we
don't really even need a row so just to
demonstrate what's going on if I again
were to try this out and just click on
one of these
we should have now have a glass of red
attached to that which we do but we
didn't actually declare a style for it
so let's go back here and say all of red
is equal to background color of red
the necessary get a read every time we
click
which is pretty awesome so secondly
let's go ahead and make a column of
black because we know we're gonna have a
red in a black player
and again I'll do it next black
so at this point what we want to do is
kind of alternate between if I was
player red or a powers player black so
up here we can just go ahead and add a
another member to this class and I'll
say player is equal to red so we started
off as player red and then after we drop
that cell into the grid we just need to
kind of switch around the player
well if I wanted to kind of switch from
player red to player black on this
member here
we first need access or we need to keep
reference to the original objects so a
little hack if you're familiar with
JavaScript you typically have to do
something like this
retain access to the original this
attribute
um
may say okay Lauren wanted to just use a
fat arrow here but the issue is I also
need access to the event called this and
this function
instead on line 29 I was going to say
constant that is equal to this and then
down here I can say that dot player
is equal to and then if player is
already equal to red I'm going to change
it to black otherwise I'll change it to
red this is gonna kind of alternate
between placing a red piece and a black
piece and of course here we can say that
dot player instead of just placing red
every single time and up here outside
these two functions instead of placing
read every time we hover or removing
read every time we hover you could
instead just say that did not player as
well
again recap we added a player attribute
to the class which is going to be either
the string red or the string black
and then as we enter or leave or click
on these different columns we're going
to be using that to remove classes and
add classes so the first thing is if
we're player
actually one second there's an issue so
as we hover we see that we are placing
next - black but I think the color is
not food
because
five is the point we change it to black
so now as we hover over we have black
okay
let's start over first player that goes
is red and when he clicks it's going to
place a red piece and now when I move
over its going to be an indicator of a
black when I click it's going to place a
black piece
so I can just go ahead and keep
alternating between these which is
pretty cool
one thing I noticed is that when I click
doesn't show up anymore and also there
should be a pointer so the first thing I
do here is go back to all them I'll say
column of Mt
a pointer our cursor is equal to pointer
now when we hover over empty cells it's
going to be a pointer and the second but
I'm trying to fix is once you click I
want the indicator to show up
automatically again the next player
Oh to fix that bug
the code really quick and try to
understand what's going on I think
basically we all we need to do is just
kind of force the event mouse enter to
trigger on the piece that we just
least I believe
empty cell
obviously need to remove that we can
also remove um
next that not player
change that to hectic
the string there
and then update player at the very end
and then of course we need to just
invoke that Mouse leave or mouse enter
function on that column like say this
dot Mouse or this dot trigger else enter
see if that kind of fixes the issue
okay which it kind of does
shoes that were retaining
that last piece that we did so spent
some time trying to figure out what the
issue is and I think it's because I'm
adding um mouse inter trigger right
before we switch the player and instead
we need to do it after
so if I were to do this okay I think
that's working as is
oh so now we have the functionality to
alternate between the different players
so red player and black player and at
this point I think this is a good
stopping point to again commit our
changes so I'm gonna go ahead and say a
alternate alternating between players go
ahead and add that push that to the repo
well so we have a really cool connect
for grid that we can click and play
around with to alternate between red and
black so now the next step is once we
place these pieces
do we know if they player wins when they
connect for
whenever we click a piece right after
that we need to check the grid see if
someone has one or not
Oh to do so let's go ahead and just
start off with making another function
and that function I'm going to call is
check for winter
inside this function as to parameters or
arguments is going to take is the row in
the column that you last clicked so for
an example let's say we were to click on
this column here and place that black
one at this point we need to then check
if there's a diagonal by a vertical or a
horizontal row or line which allows that
last piece which was black to win so if
I were to click and check in those
directions if that last piece dropped
wins and we know that the game is over
so basically what we can do is inside
the click method before we change the
player we could just do a Const winner
is equal to that dot check for winner
and I'm going to pass in
the row in the column
I can say ro and I get they call them
here
and in fact we could just go ahead and
parse these as yNN's
the partisans
um
yeah when we click on the cell we just
go ahead and check for a winner of row
and column and then down here we can see
if there is a winner we can just do some
stuff and in fact I'll just do an alert
and say game over
tick so we can do a string interpolation
so game over layer dot player
as one
and just go ahead and return out of that
and we can also kind of keep track of
well do something like that later okay
so whenever there is a winner which in
this case this function doesn't return
anything so if this function does return
a string or a boolean or something
that's equivalent to true and it's going
to print out this alert
so to implement this function let's go
ahead and go down to check for winter
in what we want to do
is we kind of want to check on all the
different directions mm-hmm so
horizontally vertically or diagonally if
there are four in a row
so to kind of start off I'm just gonna
write a first function so I'll say
return check verticals
assumes that we have a function called
check verticals up here I'll say
function check verticals and what check
verticals is going to do is we want to
have it return a call to a function
called check win so inside here I'm just
going to pass it on some directions I
remember we were two so if we take a
step back and just think let's say we
pass in a row of two and column of two
if we were to check the verticals we
know that we needed to check in the
direction up in the direction down so
here for check when we're just going to
assume that there's a function called
check when and that's going to have
Direction a and a Direction B
in in this case four verticals we can
just pass an eye of negative 1 and J of
0
we can check in the
direction so I of one in J of zero as
well
is going to kind of pass in a direction
which is going up in this case and the
direction B would be going down in this
case
and so at this point the function check
win is what we need to do is kind of sum
up all of the tokens are cells that
match the current players color
up here I'll say that is equal to this
just so we can keep track of that just
in case many player come inside here
we're going to say keep track of the
total which is going to be
equal to one
we're gonna have another matchstick
called check direction of a and we're
gonna also check the direction of E and
so what I mean by this is obviously the
piece we just placed down is going to be
equivalent to one we know that there's
already one piece that's red now we need
to check in the up direction in this
case which is a negative one and then we
also need the check in the down
directions which is going to be I of one
and Jacob zero
and so if the total added up you know
one plus everything above which is also
read and everything below which is also
read is equal to 4 or greater so I can
say if total is greater than equal to 4
we know that we can just return the
player that we found so I could say that
not player
and then otherwise we could just return
in all because we haven't found an
actual player who has won yet so to get
to the player that is at the cell that
we just clicked on
right now that that player may not let's
see if that not players fine
look for winter yeah because we don't
change the player until after so this is
fine
the next method we need to do is a Czech
Direction method so I'll say direction
inside the truck direction method what
we need to do is basically increment in
that direction while we're still inside
the grid and check if the color that we
just hit also matches the color that
we're looking for so I'm going to say
let total is equal to one let's keep
track up the number of slots that we
found that if the exact same color that
we're looking for said let is equal to
that's going to be equal to the road
those passed in plus the direction in
the I direction and then let J is equal
to the column plus the direction in the
J direction
now this point if let's say we were
checking the direction up we're just
going to go ahead and add in like one
step further
check it and then we can just go ahead
and get the cell so we don't really have
a method to do that so let's just go
ahead and write a function called get
cell takes in a row in a column
and what we can do is just return using
jQuery
same row which matches that so if I were
this
Act I'll do I do a give me the road that
is equal to the I
and give me the column which is equal to
J
now we have a method for getting the
jQuery cell I'll do money sign gets sell
and then here I can say let sell is
equal to get sell of inj
so at this point we've gotten the cell
which is one iteration above the current
one that we dropped again if we were to
click here it will grab as this one
above and what we're going to do is just
keep on doing this logic while we're
still in bound so I can say while I is
equal to zero
and I is less than two that dot rows and
J is greater than equal to zero
equal to that columns
or is it less than that columns and then
finally I can say while the player that
we're currently looking at is still
equal to the player that we just dropped
we need to keep incrementing and doing
this loop again so I guess a total plus
plus the I is plus equal to step of I
anything with Jay
you
and of course increment next the next is
equal to get the cell of inj
the next
one day I'm not sure if we're adding to
the actual cell that we dropped is there
so I'm gonna say last empty cell dot
data of player is equal to that player
but we actually know what you know cell
is set to what player
so that was a win in the vertical
direction let's go ahead and see if this
is going to crash when we're just
playing around with it
we're already getting an error so let me
go to the console and a is not defined
because I did not put direction a in
direction be there
yeah
you
all right so check directions step is
not defined
is actually called direction
provided step let's try it again
all right so now we're running into an
issue where it's not saying the game is
over when it should um so what we can do
is a little bit of debugging here and
say obviously the winner is not been set
correctly
let's see well because I'm not returning
the total here
again keep on trying
[Music]
so it actually checks in the vertical
direction and it says player red has won
and in this case the game is over but we
can keep on placing crap because we
haven't added like a an ending condition
to our game
let's try to do the same thing with the
other directions so we need to check the
horizontals as well
[Music]
mm so if I add another function and just
call it check or is Santals
and this one's going to be attic in the
road direction but we're going to go
from left to right
I'm just gonna go ahead and say call
check verticals in or or it with the
check horizontal so that if any of these
return a string it's just going to go
ahead and return the string otherwise
it's going to return null and we know
that there's no winner if that's the
case
so now by simply adding that method here
we should be able to check wins in the
horizontal direction so if I were to
just do the same thing like this
oops Black has one alright so there's a
bug where it made player black win even
though we only dropped three let me
refresh the page by to test out the
horizontals again
so there's a bug going on let me just
double check what's going
sometimes when you run into issues like
this it just helps to start running the
debugger so here I'm just gonna go ahead
and bugger here so we kind of step
through our logic I figure out what's
going on
every time we place a key
I'm going to stop in our debugger and we
can walk through what the issue may be
X is a little bit too big so let's go
ahead and do that
you
I'm basically just setting it up so I
can just check that last case where I do
a horizontal
so here when I place this piece
we're into the debugger now and we can
kind of step through and try to figure
out where we're going so I is in the
zero Direction J is in the one direction
which means it's going to go to the
right and check over the last piece we
put was this one right here and we go
ahead and grab the cell here which is
not finding anything
you
that might be our issue
you
the reason this is negative one
it shouldn't be and this is one
to step forward and see if we can find
something
column is zero in
you
so I think the issues row and column for
some reason they're 0 and 1 but they
should be set to whatever this down here
was which was I think five is two or
something so if I were to go back to
check for winter find out what exactly
we're passing into it
column
we can refresh this page
when we click this it should be printing
out
not that value
to
but the row is not correct this should
be row 0 1 2 3 4 5 I must be adding the
incorrect data guro here
um
that is added somewhere up here I
believe we're great
room
said to row
[Music]
either of column is said to call
oh I know why because I'm I'm passing in
the one that I clicked instead of the
last you want
right so what I need to do instead
I need to pass in here
they last empty cell got data of row and
at last in cell data of
let's go ahead and see that
you're the debugger because that might
just fix the issue there
you
well so now horizontals seem to be
working fine
and the last thing we need to do is
check the in diagonals so there's gonna
be two functions we need to do for the
diagonals there is a bottom left to top
right so I'll say check diagonal
bottom left to top right and then here
we could just return check win and if we
know the directions we can say I need to
go down and then J we need to go
negative so to the left
so that would be on the point that we
clicked and go down at the left
and then also both positive up into the
right
and of course we need to use that they
check the angles here
and we could add that last method which
is going to be called check diagonal of
top left to bottom right
difference is this is going to go up
right
I'm sorry down to the right and up
and of course I'll just call it down
so now I want to say this we should be
able to check at diagonals working so go
ahead and take their red win
and it works in the top right diagonal
let's try it again with the other
diagonal
you
and it's working there as well
in fact I don't think I've checked it
with black so let me just take black win
well so that's working as well all right
so now we have the functionality to
check who won by checking the
horizontals the verticals and the
diagonals that are from top left to
bottom right and from bottom left to top
right and we ran into a little bit of
issues debugging because I named some
stuff wrong but luckily we got to see
how to debug stuff in the debugger
um I think now at this point what we
want to do is we are we're seeing some
issues so even though though the game is
over we can still play scrap down um so
what we want to do now is that we can
say add a new member called is game over
set equal to false when the game starts
and then what we can do is down here
when we have one we can say this dot I'm
sorry that dot is game over is equal to
true
then whenever this is true we could just
return on us up so if the game is
already over we don't want to be able to
click on anything
if the game is over we don't want to be
able to do any of this mouse enter stuff
let's see if I were to save this now and
then just go ahead in the game
notice that I can no longer place and
when I
over stuff nothing happens then one more
thing I'm noticing is that the hover for
empty is still there so I'm just gonna
go ahead and remove every class that has
it when the game is set to
rooo I can just go ahead and say grab me
all the Mt
cells or columns so I say call empty
I'll say remove class of
all right so let's try to make that read
win and now I don't have that pointer
cursor anymore I hover over the empty
cells
yes that I think that basically wraps up
the connect for I mean the last thing I
could probably do is I could add a
restart method into this class so I
could say restart and I could say this
dot create grid
um inside create grid I could say this
is game over is equal to false
this top player people to read again
you
see I'm not sure there's anything
go inside index.html we just go ahead
and add a restart button
a button restart
within a new time
right so when we click it
guess we can just say
um never we click the restart button
is called connect or not restart
or salt and an ID called restart to this
place want to stuff down and then
restart
oh so now it's placed in two periods I
forgot to UM what we need to do is just
empty out a container that we have
so I'm connect for power to say rate
grid I get to say board empty and that's
going to go ahead and remove all the
HTML elements from the board when we
restart
right that's pretty cool
so working
um I think okay so the last thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to be able to
display instead of hello world like when
it's your turn like it's player Reds
turn or whatever so if I go back to
index.html
side here if I say it's a span ID of
player
I would start off with like a red or
something or I can keep it blank
actually no I will keep it with red
I'll say its players or its Reds turn
it's Reds turn
is its turn okay so now we click we need
to switch it to whatever the player was
so here what we could do is just add
like a callback listener so I could say
connect or on player move equal to some
function
the
set the player texty you connect or not
player
of course we don't actually have a
non-player move cold anywhere in connect
four so if I were to go here it says the
constructor and say create a new
function on player move and then
whenever I click and place something
inside the cell I could just say that
dot on player move and call it
I click notice that it is rotating
in fact it's off-by-one it's saying the
wrong thing so instead I'm going to do
it
they're after we change the player all
right now says it's Reds turn click it
says it's blacks turn I can keep
alternating between the different
players and I can restart
so that's an issue when I restart it's
not actually changing the
appear
but what we could do is again just call
bat whenever we create the grid
whenever we restart so create the grid I
say this dot or that dot on player move
let's see what happens if this
Oh
so I'll go ahead and commit this stuff
so I'll say final stages of allowing
alternate players to check if someone as
one
push that to the repo
yeah so I don't know if that was maybe I
was too quick hopefully that was well
explained or if it wasn't too confusing
but I'll do a really quick recap one
more time basically we create an HTML
file which has
h4 so we can display its Reds turn or
blackness turn and we're changing that
every time we click or place a piece we
have this connect for div which
basically our connect for class is going
to render stuff into and then of course
we have a restart button which basically
will just restart the state of our game
and as I connect for when the grade is
created we create the grid and we set up
some event listeners
and then on every time we click on a
cell or a column we're going to just do
different things so like if it is play
Reds turn we're gonna place a red token
or if it's player blacks turn we place a
black token then same thing when we
hover over different columns we again
just change the hover State
every time we click after we click we
check to see if someone has one or the
last person last player who went to see
if they won they have we just displayed
an alert and say the game's over and
then we switch players from black to red
here we trigger house enter just because
that fixes a bug with the hover State
um yeah so again feel free to leave me
feedback let me know if this tutorial
was way too fast or fast pace
I should have slowed it down in the
future you don't want this thing to take
too long to do but I think right now
we're pushing around an hour and again
feel free to grab the project from my
repo so jeaious - connect - for and
again I'll put this on youtube so you
can easily just grab it and use it or
I'll put a link in the YouTube
description so you can play around with
it
[Music]
hopefully this Toria was useful feel
free to subscribe and look forward to
new videos in the future alright thanks
for watching